انا كل قطعه عارفه من الزبونه يعني حتى
لما بتفوت زبونه ببقى عارف شو اعطيها ونحن
هون
احنا مش انه قطع كتير وهيك لا يعني الواحد
نعمل قطعه
[موسيقى]
كنت مقدمه عند اليسا
واساسا بدهن اساسن برودكشن لابين لبنان
وايطاليا وانديا بعدين بعثوا لي ايميل انه
وقفوا فانا هون حسيت انه انه ليش انا ما
بفتح
وهيك بلشت
فتحت بامكانات كتير بسيطه يعني تقريبا هذا
برجع بعمله
طبعا في صعوبات ماليه بالاول في صعوبات
هلا كان عندنا نحن علاقه مع السبلايرز
يعني كان عنا علاقه
من شغله قبل انه هذا الشيء كتير ساعد
بالبزنسفيه وسكرنا يعني بس صارت الثوره
وهيك وبلغت كتير من الكوستر اللي كانوا
حاجزين هون حسيت انه لبزنا عم تنزل وما
عندي امكانيه بقى اكفي فيها يعني اوقفها
فهو قشطه الكورونا كفه الضرب علينا سكرت
انا بهذا الوقت واجا اربعه الحمدلله نحن
كنا مسكنين اجا كورونا كل العالم ببيوتها
قاعدين على العمل عاطلين فبلشنا نوزع
الشغل وكنت انا اخذ برميشن وروح ازورهن
وقعدتيهم الشغل وارجع اخذ شغله وجمع
القطعه وهيك صار عنا مثلا كتار وهيدي تشغل
جارتها وهذه تشغل نسوان معها وصار يكبر
الشغل يكبر يكبر وعملنا
بنبلش منحدر كولكشن انا بنزل بنقي قماش
وبكون عندي كذا قصاد دراسه يعني عم فكر
فيهم يا بكون ماشي بتعجبني ومستوحى منها
وبعمل منها موديل او انه في موديل براسي
وببلش جمع له قماشاته بس لجماعه هيك بخط
فتره
منرسمهن وبنرجع نبلش نمشي التطريز بمعنى
عشره عشان يساء التطريز كله عم بيصير
ببيوتهم بنرجع بنبلش مرحله الخياطه بخلصوا
قطعه بالتطريز بتتخيط بتخلص الكولكشن بنحس
نصنبيع بنبلش بالثانيه دغري
نحن بايجار متوجه لمراه كتير قويه مره
عندها السلف كثير عالي لانه نحن
قطعتنايت
انا كثير بحب الطيور يعني انا القماشات
اللي بحبها الطيور بحب القماشات مثل
الدفتر بحب نوع القماش وبحب دايما
يتعرف على اشياء جديده غير السوق يعني
بحبهن هون يشوفوا اشياء جديده ما شايفينها
برا
[موسيقى]